hello rejects family I'm Greg
Tony Gilroy here Tony Gill trees on
Instagram today is a sad day for Tony
and I I might not upload for the next
couple days because I'm moving and my
next-door neighbor on my best friend man
cried the other day pretty sad actually
but I was like you know what Tony you're
here I'm going to shoot my last videos
team Thor part 2 where are they now we
saw the first one of this together I
said I have to watch this with Tony Gill
yeah ready for another reaction Jenner
over here here we go here we go it's a
boy I can't pay rent with this thing
one's a pumpkin amazed I was guarding
coins they're not worth ink in God those
coins these coins are worth gazillion
human you rich no one will change they
wanted market set up a store yeah and
right yeah Asgardian where previously
owned by four that will sell like
hotcakes do you want me to think about
getting a getting a job yeah I have a
job you know my job is I save the planet
eating this machine with the words that
come out of it here this is all
acknowledge yourself no it's not
knowledge is not power the muscles the
muscles
hey you're almost all muscle I am
covered in brain and I'm more brain dude
so do you think maybe we could just
think about yourself I don't think we
can get a surgeon
dr. o Mandir I really hope somehow they
infuse Daryll into Thor Ragnarok
cautery away they can include this
aspects of it or I guess so
serious it feels like we're watching
episode AAPIs or something yeah yeah and
like Marvel needs to do that man cuz I
have everything going for them when it
comes to their movies their series now
they need to have a funny company how
they need a comedy show but a star the
colony Opera House email they do like
office cell I love that they started
showing door and I go more casual
closing yeah this that relaxed it I will
hope that somehow they also include this
side of Thor in Thor Ragnarok where he's
kind of like adjusted a little bit be
human like pretty horse yellow and laid
back and he's really cocky he's always
been cocky but I like this kind of cocky
dinosaurs is so hilarious though it's
more of a just like he's actually
children like I would want you in me
yeah if they could keep just making
little ones like this you wouldn't even
need to show like the Thor trailer yeah
I don't like a week or two before this
is making me want to watch I'm hoping
Thor Ragnarok is something as hint at
least a little given out so Ragnarok
going to be the ranking film and the
gladiator battles and all that [ __ ] but
I really really want some kind of
element here because I watch the movie
the director did what we do in the
shadows after we saw the first one cuz I
love the the first one they did it so
much I felt it I thought what we do in
the shadows okay and that's a
mockumentary kind of movie yeah vampire
yeah it's really [ __ ] hysterical in
any excels at this so this is like the
most unique kind of marketing they could
do for store right now well it's perfect
man because then you don't really have
to like give people so much of the movie
until like we're getting it after moving
so please be like dumb little this makes
for a million times more likable for
some weird reason without doing the
whole imposing us gaudy in person like
he's just a chip dude it's like it is
actually finally just you know
roommate shows it happens in a not
really until acidic ensues oh that one
was William minion 17 yeah it's like you
just keep I want more of it yeah give me
more I want to see a series oh I would
be [ __ ] great it's a fun like plenty
not trying to get it all gritty throw a
little bit of the Avengers in there it
just she'll have fun with their show and
like those little like hensel's all that
stuff but it would just be funny to have
like a show that's like really fun would
you all think of that video put your
comments below in the comment boxes
recumbents belong to do the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects follow
tony on instagram at SRI zetas following
he's been slowly developing his gaming
stuff figured he's buy your job and
figuring it's coming out at the same
time you take this time but it'll be
there one then I'll be guessing on it
what and shout out to Tony the best
neighbor I could have ever asked for
who the [ __ ] gonna live here next man
some old Nazi man and be like oh tired
of all that loud news if you're playing
we can hear each other throughout
through the wall yeah you have to scream
man cos we hear you and your girl having
sex and you constantly hear me
masturbating because I'm masturbating
while you're having this custom video